people say that I'm so controversial not
not an controversy quite like Madonna
getting the last laugh you know kind of
sticks and stones can break my bones the
names can never hurt me now here's the
back story earlier this month at the
Grammys match introduced Kim Petrus and
Sam Smith's performance Donna how good
is it to be here tonight
pretty good but instead of focusing on
Madonna's empowering speech about
inclusivity some viewers focus on
Madonna's face and took aim at her
appearance Madge called out the
criticism in a lengthy post on Instagram
writing once again I am caught in the
glare of ageism and misogyny fast
forward to Monday the iconic singer was
ready to laugh it all off
strike a pose the Queen of Pop struck a
pose in this new snap sporting braids
and a baseball cap her caption look how
cute I am now that swelling from surgery
has gone down LOL alongside a laughing
emoji I'm trying to get out of my
comfort zone the pig received tons of
Praise from fans and celebs like Eric
Benet who kept it real folks should
allow other folks to look however the F
they want to look without all the
demeaning judgmental unwanted opinions
my way of looking at the world I'm I'm
out to do something and I want to do
what I have to get there despite the
hate Madonna shared just how much fun
she had at the Grammys and the after
party
the pop star kept things hot
tongue-kissing jazz musician Jazzy
Madonna wrote at the time she's never
apologized for her creative choices the
way she looks or dresses and I'm not
going to start people say that I'm so
controversial
but I think the most controversial thing
I have ever done is to stick around
Madge please stick around and keep
trolling the haters
[Music]